could you give advice to young people in
general
uh folks in high school folks in college
how to take on some of the big questions
you've taken on now you've done that in
the space of biology and expanded out
how can they
have a career they can be proud of or
have a life they can be proud of
gosh
that's a big question
um i'm sure you've gathered some wisdom
you can uh impart yeah and just so so
the only advice that i actually ever
give to my students
um is
follow what you're interested in
because they they're often
worried that if they make this decision
now and and do this course instead of
that course then they're going to
restrict their career opportunities and
um there isn't a career path in science
it's it's not i mean that there is but
there isn't um
there's a lot of competition there's a
lot of death
symbolically
um so who survives
the people who survive are the people
who
care
enough
to still do it and they're very often
the people who
don't worry too much about the future
and are able to live in the present
because if you you know you do a phd
you've competed hard to get onto the phd
then you have to compete hard to get a
post-doc job and
you have you know the next bond maybe on
another continent and it's only two
years anyway and and so and there's no
there's no
guarantee you're going to get a faculty
position at the end of it
so and there's always the next step to
compete if you get a faculty position
you get a tenure and with 10 you go full
professor and full professor then you go
to some kind of whatever the discipline
is there's an award if you're in physics
you're always competing for the nobel
prize there's different awards yeah and
then eventually you're all competing to
i mean there's always a competition so
there is no happiness happiness does not
lie if you're looking into the future
yes and if what you're caring about is a
career then then
it's probably not the one for you
if though you can put that aside and you
know i've also worked in industry for a
brief period and
and i was made redundant twice so i i
know that uh
you know there's no guarantee she's got
a career that way either yes um so
so
live in the moment
and try and enjoy what you're doing and
that means really
go to the
go to the themes that you're most
interested in and try and follow them as
well as you can and and
that
tends to pay back in surprising ways i
don't know if you've found this as well
but i i found that
um
people will help you often if they see
some light shining in the eye and you're
excited about their subject
um
and and you know just want to talk about
it
and they know that their friend in
california's got a job coming up they'll
say go for this this guy's all right you
know
they'll they'll they'll use the network
to help you out if you really care and
you're not going to have a job two years
down the line but if you what you really
care about is what you're doing now
then it doesn't matter if you have a job
in two years time or not it'll work
itself out if you've got the light in
your eye
um
and so
that's the only advice i can give and
most people
probably
drop out through that system because the
fight is just not worth it for them
yeah when you have the light in your eye
when you have the excitement for the
thing what happens is you start to
surround yourself with others they're
interested in that same thing that also
have the light if you really are
rigorous about this because
i think it does take it's it doesn't
it takes effort
to make oh you've got to be obsessive
but but if you're doing what you really
love doing then it's not work anymore
it's what you do yeah but i also mean
the surrounding yourself with other
people that are obsessed about the same
thing because
depending on that takes some work as
well yeah just you know and look finding
the right yeah finding the right mentors
the collaborators because i think one of
the problem with
the phd process is
people are not careful enough in picking
their mentors those are people
mentors and colleagues and so on those
are people going to define
the the direction of your life how much
you love a thing how much i mean the
power of just like the few little
conversations you have
in the hallway
it's it's incredible so you have to be a
little bit careful in that sometimes you
just get randomly almost assigned
really
pursue
i suppose the subject
as much as you pursue the people that do
that subject so like the both the whole
dancing they kind of go together really
yeah they do they really do but take
that that
that part seriously and probably in the
way you're describing it
careful how you define success
because uh you'll never find happiness
in success and there's a lovely quote uh
from robert louis stevenson i think who
said nothing in life is so disenchanting
as attainment
yeah so i mean in some sense
the the the true definition of success
is
you getting to do today
what you really enjoy doing just uh what
fills you with joy and that's ultimately
success so success isn't the thing
beyond the horizon the big stat the the
the big trophy the the financial i think
it's as close as we can get to happiness
that's not to say you're full of joy all
the time but it's it's as close as we
can get to a sustained human happiness
is by getting some fulfillment from what
you're doing on a daily basis and if
what you're looking for
is the
the the world giving you the stamp of
approval with a nobel prize or a
fellowship or whatever it is then you
know i've known people like this who
they
they're eaten away
by the
by the anger the kind of caustic
resentment that they've not been awarded
this prize that they deserve
and the other way if you put too much
value into those kinds of prizes and you
win them
i've got the chance to see
that it also
the more quote unquote successful you
are in that sense the more you run the
danger of
um
growing ego so big that you don't get to
actually
enjoy the beauty of this life you start
to believe that you figured it all out
as opposed to
i think what the ultimately the most fun
thing is is being curious about
everything around you being constantly
surprised and these little moments of
discovery of enjoying
enjoying beauty and small and big ways
all around you and i think the bigger
your ego grows the more you start to
take yourself seriously the less you're
able to enjoy that
oh man i couldn't agree more
you